hello mindless cogs and welcome to the
seven million Habits of Highly Effective
Hampton Deville employees habit number
428 remember everyone's name remembering
the names of co-workers makes you seem
invested in and focused on the company
and if you have a hard time remembering
people's names try this handy little
trip associate names with memories that
mean something to you for instance I
associate John's name with the memory of
an earthquake that destroyed my child at
home and I associate Kate's name with
the memory of the affair I had with the
admissions director at Yale
his name was Glenn worst case scenario
if you can't remember someone's name you
can always just be like how are your
adorable little your parents how are you
adorable little fantastic yeah great oh
by the way my name is John and that's
how you do it